yeah welcome to yet another five-minute
game and it's black against the most joy
something from germany german flag at
least and a news oh okay 3i castle and
let's see you know maybe we get the no
line after all yeah this is an
interesting line I haven't decided yet
what to do in the book oh this is very
uncommon taking with the night it takes
d4 sir bye father the most common move
and frankly I don't understand 94 what
is the idea okay I can take a couple of
points now he's got bishop age seven
though that's am one idea okay let's
just take here and after takes on c3 is
very playing Bishop by seven so not
threatening much but maybe just retreat
and asking white what exactly is your
compensation for your for your bed
structure
p 6 was also possible maybe b6 man i
defiled ok so i just want to play knight
c6 and complete development
so so i moved to protect it or just 96
good question yeah after 96 we probably
have fun lots of exchanges with an equal
position it's a bit dull okay let's
let's try something else
Jim probably this wasn't the greatest
idea ever this looks quite good for
white 95
and wow yeah I should have just played
96 queen bee six was really a bad idea
oh man 95 what what what am I playing
against this should be 297 you know this
is this may be a maybe also good don't
have much choice
Bishop b4 Queenie for takes on f6 mmm
very very ugly yeah but what else
yeah just 24 takes Queen air for
something this looks really ugly for
black
okay so let's let's wrap here if you
attacks f6 hmm
hmm I had to complete the hallucination
there I cannot come ahead with queen bee
20 this doesn't look good so let's say
queen a fall what am i doing again the
smooth I can maybe play box yet trying
to get counterplay maybe it is some it
just looks really slow come on let's try
to get some capital play
i take c 4
5 f-5 F is got Lucy one
can also play just King g7 or queen g4
doesn't help so much okay
you
so let's assume on
you
yeah Quincy to was my idea getting it at
the seaport now
draw comfort hmm countess a destroy show
I want to try a bit just a bit mostly
because if people have spot the
advantage they quite often give away
even more but it's probably just it's
nothing I don't have any advantage just
trying to get something on the second
rank here Queen 82 now this is probably
just nonsense you should have taken the
drawn
check yeah now we can ya give tons of
checks anyway and probably will he's
down on time
can you get a look at seven I don't
think so check check yeah we can always
take the draw draw Harvard check gave
wrong yeah not much to do yeah I was
simply worse I can be I must be glad
that that I wasn't completely wiped out
here this looks looks terrible yeah I
hear the computer just once though wants
to take on c6 with a substantial
advantage yeah just winced upon
basically yeah this was a disaster I'm
Queen Queen B 6 verse was terrible
Bishop e3 wants to come the computer
once even better yeah I just must I must
play play something else here maybe
maybe really just knight c6 here normal
move probably a white is even slightly
better here maybe here I need to need to
develop the coincide first 9075
something like this it should be alright
for black I cannot believe but should be
better but the way I played I was in big
trouble okay thanks for watching